is pervasive misogyny a myth
I've claimed that it is
yeah I think
before we got on here I was talking
about how I was treated in Cairo yeah
tell that story
and I was getting onto an elevator I was
there first I hit the button I started
to step on and these two guys walk up
and they're like no no and they waved to
me to get off and then I got off and
they got on and they went up and I had
to take the next one
um so that kind of thing exists in
places in the world still in 2023
um but in the U.S uh you're not getting
much of that anymore and in fact you're
getting quite a bit of the opposite so I
wrote this paper I think this is this a
quote article I think yeah yeah a year
or two ago
um that reviewed a lot of the recent uh
research on looking at gender biases and
psychology and a lot of the time you see
exactly the opposite so people are
biased in favor of women across a lot of
different domains they often treat women
better than men they like women better
than they like men women get punished
less than men for the same things
um when there's a scientific finding
that portrays men better than women
people are biased against it in relation
to Scientific evidence that portrays
women better than men so people want
women to be better than men
um and so this idea that
Society is sexist against women and we
have to be vigilant about potential harm
to women
um I think potentially actually stems
from the very fact that we care so much
more about women than we do about men
and when we discover these biases
against men no one really cares and they
don't make the headlines
um
so yeah I would say it is largely a myth
in modern Western societies yes is it
really possible to answer this question
about whether Society is more biased
against men than women
that's a good question and I would say
probably no like practically it would be
really hard to measure all of the
different contexts
where people potentially could be biased
uh so like some Scholars have looked at
potential bias against men and women in
Academia and they see for example it's
possible students are slightly biased
against women and they're teaching
evaluations although hard to know
because a lot of these are real
evaluations so it could just be that
what maybe women aren't as NICE T-Shirts
I don't know
um
um so people have tried to like look at
which domains do people have a bias
against women or against men it would be
hard to look at everything all at once
and say uh which direction but one thing
that's been happening that I've seen
across a few papers now including one of
my own papers that's coming out is that
a lot of these biases actually used to
favor men like for example in hiring for
male stereotypical jobs it really was
the case that people used to be
discriminating against women in those
jobs
um and a lot of these things seem to
have flipped around 20 2009 so a lot of
the biases that used to favor men now
favor women and a lot of the biases that
always favor women still favor women so
I do think uh I I don't know if we can
say on whole who gets treated worse
relative to the other gender
um but certainly it seems to be the
trajectory that biases are increasingly
in favor favoring women and then people
just don't seem to care as much about
that as when they
seem to go against women there was that
Steve Stuart Williams study about fake
articles favoring women or men and
people's judgments of it right yeah they
had one on I think it was men or women
lie more me baby and then they did men
or women are more intelligent or men and
women better drawers I think they're
like three domains and yeah they always
found that when that when the evidence
said that women have a worse quality
than men people are like this is sexist
this is bad research but when women are
portrayed as better people like oh it's
even pretty good
same as when it was equal right so women
are better and men and women are equal
was seen as
um a similar level I think so I have
studies where I've looked at something
very similar that I have struggled to
publish for like seven years uh where we
did that we had men or I think we did it
with intelligence men or women are
equally intelligent women are more
intelligent than men are men are more
intelligent than women and people like
the men and women are equally
intelligent or women are more
intelligent than men more than they like
men are more intelligent than women so
that's the one that really irritates
people yeah why do you think this is the
case like why is it well actually first
no why do mainstream narratives Focus so
much on the possibility of anti-female
biases
if it seems you know pretty robust that
men even have an anti-men bias like the
call is coming from inside the house
with regards to some of the some of the
sort of anti-male sentiments yeah so
like both men and women will show this
pro-female bias it is larger for females
usually but men too have these Pro women
pre-pro woman advice um
what was your question why do mainstream
narratives focus on it so much oh
um yeah I think I think it's potentially
just because we care more but so okay so
there are two things going on I think uh
and one I think has been sort of
forwarded as the explanation but I think
it might be a little bit simplistic so
um just the idea that men and women you
know women have more like value
essentially from an evolutionary
perspective if you have a hundred women
100 women and one men one men one man
you can have a hundred babies but if you
have one more
very happy man if you have uh one woman
and a hundred men you gotta have one you
know you have a very disgusting woman
yeah yeah exactly
um so so women are the sort of limited
resource and so Scholars have argued and
it seems to be uh very plausible that
you know we care more about harm to
women because they are essentially
setting the limit on our success as a
species so that's one piece of it the
reason that I don't think that's
necessarily all of it is what we briefly
touched on at the start of this
conversation which is that you do see
these big cross-cultural differences and
you do you see these big differences
over time so if I were to run this study
where say like men are smarter than
women or Women are Smarter than men in
like 1920 would I see the same thing I
highly doubt it
um so I don't think that's all of it I
think that's part of it and then on top
of it we have this sort of cultural
narrative that you know women have been
disadvantaged for x amount of time
um and that is a huge problem and and
now the corrective measures have gone so
far that they've fully reversed things
and a lot of time men are being
disadvantaged for the sake of women so I
think those are both what's happening so
you see that in society when you get any
of these effects where you're like look
people are sexist against women everyone
loves it you know goes viral it's
covered by the New York Times uh I don't
think anybody will be well I don't want
to say anybody but I don't know if Steve
stew Steve Stuart Williams findings are
going to make it to the front page of
New York Times I guess we'll see are you
uh are you familiar with gamma bias have
you learned about this I don't know no I
don't think so so this is a Dr John
Barry from the center for male
psychology this is a concept that he at
least has popularized I don't know
whether he was the one that came up with
it and it basically talks about how
especially in popular news uh media
articles if the article is pro-women
then they will sex the headline if it's
anti-men then it will sex the headline
but if it's the reverse it will be
gender neutral uh so basically the the
successes of women and the failings of
men both end up getting so um like white
male shooter would be put as the
headline for something or like um female
CEO would be putting as a headline for
something but the reverse isn't
necessarily true uh it seems to be less
true and this causes a skew in the way
that people see the world you know more
people are spending time inside rather
than outside now which means that their
genuine day-to-day experience of the
world is limited so most of them live
their life vicariously through the news
stories that they read and the social
media that they follow which means that
this very much is shaping our experience
of the world yeah I think q1 2023 saw
the highest ever number of female CEOs
in history happen it was over a third of
all CEOs were women remembering that
this isn't just like finally women have
got the opportunity to do this this is
like finally we have found enough women
that want to become CEO or for all that
it sounds great and like 50 50.
the reality on the ground probably sucks
a lot more dick than you think so um you
also found looking at this this issue
that uh psychology academics also have
this bias too
um Jedi yeah wasn't it that um people
have like a stronger desire to censor
science that this favors women oh
um yeah yeah yeah so that's in my right
yeah the where I surveyed psychology
professors well first I interviewed them
um and I asked them this was this was
this was from forever ago this was I
think he must have found the teaser that
maybe got you onto this track originally
because this was way before you started
this study unless you were doing that
study like two or three years ago when
you wrote that Collette article
I probably wha or I possibly was yeah
was it my own research or was it someone
else's research I'm not sure what you
had was an inclination I think that both
the um way that the general public and
the way that the people doing the
science that the general public sees
everybody is kind of aware of this like
you know both men and women seem to have
a pro-female bias when it comes to the
way they interpret stuff that boundary
doesn't stop outside of academics and
Academia that seeps into Academia too
the difference being that Academia is
Upstream of these realizations so there
are academics who are concerned about
that okay so we've like danced around
what's going on what is your explanation
for why this is happening not why
mainstream media focuses on it like why
is it the case that this is the
interpretation
that the interpretation is that the
world is sexist against women yeah
um
yeah
um motivated reasoning I don't know
there are a couple things I mean one is
just what I mentioned before is that we
do have this greater concern for women
there's this cultural shift and part of
that cultural shift is driven by the
fact that women now as you mentioned
like they're more in positions of power
and so their interests
um they the the interests of women have
more power in institutions they probably
I mean if women are taking over the
media they're taking over science
they're taking over all of these
positions and they're particularly
concerned about their own interests um
they're going to focus on that even as
the problem disappears over time but as
you said there's also this
actual I think
sincere but incorrect belief about the
problem so in this paper that we should
have hopefully getting accepted any day
now
um we had academics and everyday people
estimate discrimination against men and
women in hiring contexts in these audit
studies where you know you're randomly
um uh sending in apple job applications
to real jobs with like a female or a
male name
um and as I said we see this flip around
2009 where all of a sudden
um even for male stereotypical jobs the
biases favor women they've always
favored women for female stereotypical
jobs but among everyday people and
academics alike
everyone assumes it's the opposite they
assume that there's this huge bias
against women in hiring for male male
stereotypical jobs
um so they think like they look at just
the underrepresentation of women in stem
and say well there can be only one
explanation obviously we're
discriminating against women in stem and
it's not oh maybe maybe women don't want
to go into stuff maybe they like other
things more
um so you know there's that tendency to
see if there's a disparity and we know
that historically women have
discriminated uh been discriminated
against then that must be the best and
the only explanation in fact
um and so it's this combination of like
who's who's in power so those people's
interests are like starting to have a
greater impact on public narratives in
the media and Academia
um but also I just think there's this
misperception about what's actually
happening uh that that maybe it's driven
by what you say what the media are
covering
um
maybe it's willful ignorance I don't
know I I think that definitely a part of
it is there's no Associated social
Renown or Goodwill for anybody that
starts really uploading men doing well
as CEOs you know there's no
um victimhood card carrying points
available for somebody that decides to
do that because [__] you this is no
surprise to anybody like you know you
know even taking it from a straight up
structural perspective
headlines that are counter-intuitive or
at least sound counter-intuitive are the
ones that are the most interesting so
why are we going to report on a news
story that most people already thought
was happening so you kind of have this
public conceptual inertia that most
people think the world is one particular
way that means that when stories appear
that confirm the world view that they
thought they had they get brushed under
the rug why should we be bothered about
celebrating the number of men becoming
CEOs or guys doing whatever whatever
because this is the way it's always been
because they don't know that there may
be some shift in the other direction
which would make now the intuitive
counter-intuitive again so it's almost
like there's a mismatch between what's
actually happening and what the Press is
uh releasing and what the public
believes but you know and this is not to
castigate women it's not like women are
choosing to make this like misunder I
don't think almost any women
well
what do you think
I I can see why some women would maybe
have this sort of misandrous or desire
to be
um to continue to castigate man you had
this quote a Google Scholar search for
misogyny yielded 114
000 results whereas a search for
misunder yielded only 2 340. so people
are not studying or really concerned
about anti-male bias especially from
women and it's the same as the like can
black people be racist question it's
like no of course they can't like racism
is power plus plus privilege given that
women are the ones who have been out of
power for so long there is no way that
they could be like I bet that if you did
on Street interviews or you surveyed
people saying like can women be sexist
that it would yield very very similar
results I think that's probably there's
actually an even better Google result
that I think I didn't find until after I
wrote that paper but I Google imaged
uh men are stronger than women which is
just empirically correct on average and
not even on average it's like it's just
yeah almost exclusively yeah
um barely barely an overlap um but of
the like 41st images that popped up on
the screen I think
like one of them was yes confirming that
and then there were like two neutral and
all the rest were images of men being of
women being stronger than men so women
running faster than men women like you
know raising a man over her head you
know
um and so even when you Google this this
fact men are stronger than women
everyone's like no women are stronger
than men there was a football game that
happened a couple of weeks ago in the UK
I can't remember the team but they got
like the B Squad of some fourth division
oh yeah British team to play I think the
US Women's team and they beat them I
want to say like 12 nil or 14 nil in the
space of 25 minutes and then the the the
best uh presentation I think of speed
and power the disparity between men and
women is the women's hundred meter
record so the women's hundred meter
record that hasn't been beaten in I want
to say 20 or 30 years
is held by like a hundred or two hundred
under 18 males like like high school
level males hit that that female number
but that's because of socialization as
we all know
um but yeah there have been a couple of
cases where they try to get these
professional female athletes to play
yeah like low tier men's teams and it
doesn't go well it's embarrassing
it's not embarrassing like necessarily
but it is just because we're in denial
of this reality uh for whatever reason
yeah if you were to do a game of uh lie
detection or um turning over cards on a
table and having to remember the
position of them all if that had
happened to become a globally recognized
sport for some reason women would wipe
the floor with men we would be like this
is completely unfair we can't have a
mixed co-ed uh a team of this because
you know for some reason all of the top
players happen to be women because they
are we better at that game yeah I
thought what's it called local station
local memorization or local
spatialization or something like that
I've heard that but I didn't know it
translated to that game but I guess that
makes sense that's the only thing that I
can think of that's like a modern
equivalent of it either that or losing
your keys in the kitchen that you know
like every guy loses the keys but every
woman knows exactly where they are but
if the guy then went to throw the keys
to the woman like she's not catching
them men can be like looking at an odd
object and be like where's my yeah
precisely correct yeah precisely correct
Okay so we've kind of got a bit of a
story going on here we've set up this um
disparity between what people think is
happening in the world and what might
actually be happening some anti-female
anti-male Pro male anti-female bias
there's also moving into higher
education a lot more women who are going
into higher education not only as
students but also as academics too
how has this changed academic culture
women
look at men it's I think it actually
goes ever so slightly up but for women
it's like huge you know they were a very
very small minority
um decades ago not even all that long
ago but in the past few years women are
dominating at the undergraduate level
way more women than men there are more
women in graduate school and now there
are actually more women who are faculty
as well so you went from an institution
that was run
almost entirely by men and the people in
the institution were almost all men too
because the students were meant to
um and now it's a majority of women and
I think I don't want to say it's the
only cause I don't think it is the only
cause but I do think it is probably
probably a primary contributor to a lot
of the cultural shifts that have been
happening in the past 10 years because
they all prioritize the values of women
so if you look at stuff
for example you know people wanting to
do these trigger warnings when they're
teaching topics in class if you look at
the cases of Scholars getting attacked
or fired or harassed on social media for
studying you know potentially
controversial topics those are
skyrocketing if you look at these
editorial changes in academic journals
which maybe some of your listeners won't
be familiar with but there have been
some of the most prominent or most
prestigious journals in all of Science
of the nature Springer family of
journals that have put out a series of
editorials over these past few years
saying that they would not
publish and potentially would retract
science that has like potential to
um
I think one of the phrasing was
undermine the Dignity of human social
groups uh whatever that means
um and so it's all of these like harm
concerns and these concerns about
protecting vulnerable people
um that are starting to interfere with a
process that at least at one point was
supposed to be well we're going to
pursue the truth you know if it hurts
some people's feelings you know that so
be it that's not what we're concerned
with we're concerned with
um you know finding out what is
empirically correct about the world and
sharing that information with our
students
um and so if you look at all each and
then the the growing the bloated uh Dei
um
uh
what do you call it initiative
initiative divisions whatever they have
at these these universities all of these
things are uh
they all kind of concern the things that
women would be worried about and so
you're getting this exact
pattern happening at the same time women
are essentially taking over Academia and
now they're probably holding more
positions of power they're the editors
at these journals they're the presidents
of the professional societies
um they're they're the administration
um
it's kind of like exactly what you would
expect if you changed the gender
composition of Academia and people are
so uh perplexed by it but it seems like
a pretty simple straightforward uh
solution I'm not saying that's the only
thing maybe social media has something
to do with it you know scientists are
directly at like interacting with the
public so maybe the public gets pissed
about a scientific finding whereas 15
years ago they probably didn't even know
we had academic journals
um so that could be part of it but yeah
I think the changing the composition the
gender composition of Academia
um I think pretty much has inevitable
consequences that are going to
prioritize the interests of women which
are to protect the vulnerable from harm
um and they're also way more egalitarian
so they want
they want everyone to kind of have the
same outcomes whereas men are more
hierarchical they're more comfortable
with like some people are going to be
better at things than other people and
those people are going to get
um benefits for that um I've known women
who you know I know a lot of women in
Academia and a lot of them are like
pained by the process of grading like
they don't want to give anyone a d which
I get like it's not fun
um failing a student but that's kind of
part of the process if you just give
everyone an a it sort of loses its
meaning but that's that's painful to
women to to not have everyone be
thriving equally all the time can you
explain for the people who are
uninitiated can you explain the driver
evolutionarily about why women have this
more egalitarian more sort of Cloak and
Dagger behind closed doors approach to
things and and the opposite for men
yeah so women essentially women were
having children and raising them to be
successful adults that have children of
their own
um whereas men were often working in
coalitions to protect the group so men
are used to uh creating coalitions
figuring out who's a good leader who's
good at what giving that person status
to make sure the group works really well
together
um so they're they're very comfortable
with the fact that some men are going to
rise to the top because that benefits
the whole group if we have a strong
leader we all live
um women were not participating in that
so much they were they were being
protected by the men and their primary
job was to care for Offspring and keep
the keep Offspring alive so they have
this concern for things that are
vulnerable and they want to protect them
and help them
um
the the I I think it's actually sort of
an interesting discussion about like is
it that men are hierarchical or women
egalitarian because it it might just be
that the egalitarian thing could have
been the default but men are the ones
that had to change because they had to
coordinate and cooperate in this way in
order who's the operation who's the dude
I don't know so like I think and I think
that explanation it's almost like the
absence of women participating in that
potentially made them more egalitarian
but it also could have been because you
know their their sharing Resources with
other women and helping other women take
care of their their children too
um where you wouldn't necessarily need
their they tend to be in small groups
um prefer you know a few close friends
rather than being in this huge group of
people that's really coordinated and
trying to out-compete other groups uh
Joyce beninson has done so much good
work on this where she looked at uh is
it female basketball teams and I think
male
oppositioned male opponents on a
basketball court show more Goodwill
physically to each other than
female compatriots
so like enemies on the men teams they
show more love to each other than the
same team the the same team members for
for women and I
tell me if I'm wrong here I'm pretty
sure that another contributing reason is
that women physically are more fragile
which means that getting uh becoming the
enemy of anybody has higher consequences
and you are physically less capable of
Defending yourself plus you potentially
have dependence on you children so on
and so forth so the externality of you
dying like man dies not good but like
you know things can continue because
he's been gauled by a [__] Mammoth or
something uh woman gets too high above
her station she pisses off the wrong
Other Woman and that woman
poisons are in asleep or takes a child
away from her or does something else to
cause her to
um lower down in status which means that
women seem to hide their own successes I
think this is born out of
um the way that girls in school talk
about achieving a grades and B grades
and C grades that they're much more
disparaging of their own achievements
they will underplay their own
achievements a lot more it's the same
thing of um
if you if a girl thinks that her results
are going to be viewed by other people
she's much more likely to downplay her
successes whereas if she thinks that
they're going to be kept private they'll
be a little bit more um accurate or full
of themselves in in their assessments uh
so that's another sort of contributing
factor too I wasn't aware of that that
last one but yeah there are pretty
consistent gender differences where like
men have more self-esteem than women
women tend to underestimate how well
they're doing at things and men tend to
overestimate how well they're doing
things
well how beneficial is it and yeah as
you said I mean I don't even necessarily
think it's just women on women women are
vulnerable around men too and so I think
that there's more pressure to be a
conformist when you're a woman because
as you said you don't want to piss
anyone off because you're not
particularly uh strong and so if someone
attacks you there's a good chance you're
gonna get injured or die
um whereas men are more capable of you
know defending themselves and they're
completely capable of Defending
themselves against almost all women and
so they're like enemies are cut in half
or rather the threats are cut in half as
it were
um so so yeah there are a lot of these
like correlated gender differences that
if you look at them like on their own
the differences don't appear huge when
it comes to personality but the fact
that you get them across all of these
different kinds of things like the
egalitarianism and the harm concern that
I think the pressure to to be uh to
conform to your social group
when when all of those things are
correlated you end up with these pretty
big differences and then we see these
differences in the priorities of men and
women so
among psychology professors men are more
supportive of pursuit of Truth as like
the purpose of science than women are
they're more supportive of academic
freedom than women are whereas women
think we need to be balancing these
things with moral concerns and harm
concerns
um so you get these you know evolved
gender differences between men and women
their personality and then you change
the gender composition of an institution
and it can fundamentally change the goal
of what that institution is trying to
accomplish in the case of science like
truth so long as it doesn't cause any
mean stereotypes to be spread about it
I've got some of my favorite stats that
you found during your research 56
percent of men said that colleges should
not protect students from offensive
ideas 64 percent of women said that they
should 51 of men said colleges should
not disinvite speakers if students
threaten violent protest 67 of women
said that they should 58 of men opposed
a confidential reporting system at
colleges which students could use to
report offensive comments 54 of women
supported it 50 63 of men thought
controversial news stories in student
newspapers should not need
administrators approval before
publication 51 women thought that they
should and it just continues down
whether it's about willingness to report
mail counterparts for dismissal
campaigns 71 of men reported that
protecting free speech is more important
than promoting an inclusive Society
sixty percent of women said that
promoting an inclusive Society is more
important than protecting Free Speech
all the way down then you summarize it
really really nicely here put simply men
are relatively more interested in
advancing what is empirically correct
and women are relatively more interested
in advancing what is morally desirable
yeah what I love about all of those
numbers too is because they so clearly
show what happens when you change the
majority representation in an
institution because in all of those
cases it's the majority of men hold view
a and the majority of women hold you be
so whichever group has more people
they're going to be the ones whose
uh priorities when we call it like the
the academic ratio hypothesis yeah we
could and and I mean I haven't actually
gotten much pushback on it which I
really thought I would at one point and
I think part of the reason I haven't
gotten as much pushback as I would
expect
um for such a claim oh awesome everybody
um is because
women actually think that it's good that
they're like that right so to people who
think academic freedom is obviously this
really important thing and obviously
science should be pursuing truth we look
at these statistics and we're like
well [__] like this is really bad women
are potentially causing problems in
science and Academia but when women see
these statistics they're like
finally like we're saving it we're
making it a safe place for everyone and
we're making sure that science does good
it doesn't do harm
um and there's another paper that looked
at this like the priorities of
scientists men are they have this sort
of like basic interest in understanding
the world and like figuring out what's
true and figuring out how things work
whereas women do science because they
want to cause good in the world so their
their motivation is I I want to know the
truth but I only want to know the truth
if it's going to help me help other
people which means that any truth that
doesn't help me help other people and
especially any truth that potentially
could harm other people is not valuable
and we should not be pursuing it in
science and Academia
um which is you know very fundamentally
different from what I think a lot of
people thought we were doing for a long
time with science the thing that I tried
to get at earlier on
um before you sideswipe me with your
misogyny was that
I I don't want this to come across like
women haven't got their heads on
straight men you should treat them like
they haven't got a clue what they're
talking about the point is
if you were convinced of these
viewpoints you would be convinced of
them too like for the most part people
are supporting things that they believe
now they might believe them erroneously
it might be motivated reasoning it might
be because of societal pressure it might
be because they want to morally
grandstand and look like they're really
cool and important and empathetic and
all this stuff all of these reasons
contribute but like if I convince you
that two plus two equals four you can't
unconvince yourself of something that
you're convinced of up until the point
at which you are unconvinced at which
point you have a new set of views right
so it's like if you felt this way if you
had this biological predisposition plus
this sort of cultural uh imposition on
you from all the girlfriends that you'd
spend time with and the same for men too
like for the women in Academia who say I
can't believe that men don't care about
harms and blah blah blah it's like the
reason that they're convinced is because
they're convinced and being able to hold
two conflicting viewpoints in your mind
at one time is really important like
look women can hold this View and to
them it is the truth men can hold this
view unto them it is the truth right
like it's a case of trying to bridge
that divide I think to help people
understand okay from first principles
what are we trying to achieve right with
Academia like what's the goal here what
are we actually trying to get ourselves
toward and I do think that it would lean
more toward the male side of this it's
going to be toward the man it's going to
be truth but but do you just so the one
thing that I thought about it's like how
do you just like why like how do you
justify why science should be pursuing
truth
is it just uh is it just itself a good
or is there a reason that we care about
the truth or we should pursue truth to
me the goal of science would be to
accurately represent what is going on in
the world and why is that good why is
that better because that can inform
decisions moving forward accurately
if you do it based on some
predisposition some sort of uh
predetermination or some motivated
reasoning you're going to encounter a
situation in which the world doesn't
reflect what your research has
supposedly shown or what missed research
would have shown because you haven't
been trying to represent what the world
is but why is that bad because you're
going to end up with massive errors
you're going to end up with people
predicting things that don't come true
or not predicting things that do come
true that could have been discovered had
the research been done but why do why
are errors bad
why are errors bad I guess that's a good
question because Downstream Downstream
from errors you would end up with a
world that isn't able you would end up
with a society in a civilization that
isn't able to accurately perceive what
is going on
that to me just seems like like what
what is science if science isn't
understanding what's happening in the
world
and downstream from that being able to
accurately make predictions
I don't understand what we're doing here
like we why don't we just write fiction
if that's I was trying to lead you down
a path and you didn't take the bait okay
bait me what should I have said well
where I was gonna try to get like
I I've seen myself do I'm a person who
thinks science should be pursuing truth
first and foremost and I don't think
other moral concerns should interfere
with that unless they're like
catastrophic and definitely going to
happen
um
but I find myself justifying that with
consequences which is if we don't have
the truth we're going to waste all this
time on these [__] interventions
that aren't going to accomplish anything
they're not going to deliver on their
promises you know they might actually
cause harm to people and so I'm like
bringing in the harm element to justify
why we should be pursuing the truth
um but it sounds like you think truth is
maybe just like in itself a good which I
would like to argue that but I'm like
well where does that value come from is
it just like that's just something
humans think because truth is tends to
be useful and so we've come to sort of
worship the truth yeah and when I try to
justify it I go
prevent harm and then I'm doing the same
thing which is oddly what the what a lot
of people are trying to do but you're
right they're going through a less
circuitous route they're just saying
okay we won't ever talk about anything
that could harm somebody and you're like
that's the first order effect the second
order effect might be that they end up
being harmed because the thing that
you've researched or not researched is
the thing that could have protected them
from the harm in the end yeah I think
exactly I think I was um really really
poorly talking about the implications
sunstream
um
but but it is it is interesting because
as I assume you know of that al-shably
paper on the female mentors that got uh
that the authors are connected so it's
like two two
three three summers ago maybe right
around now
um you know during that summer first
summer of covet when everyone was going
crazy uh this this young female scholar
published this paper with a couple of
colleagues and they found that um
that uh female mentees of female mentors
uh
had less impactful careers later down uh
later down their careers than male
mentees that were mentored by male
mentors so essentially this male male
combo of Mentor mentee led to more
successful outcomes than this female
females who people hated that obviously
because it makes women look like they're
not good mentors or something or women
aren't cooperating well together
um and they retracted the paper and this
is one of the and and there was all of
this talk about how this is gonna harm
women in science and it's going to cause
all these like negative consequences and
what ended up happening is like the
journal was like we're gonna launch
initiatives to help women in science so
if anything it was like helpful to women
that this paper got published but then
on the other side of it I'm thinking no
scholar let's imagine this effect is
real which I don't think we have a good
reason to doubt it no one like really
criticized finding they criticized like
the operationalizations and stuff
um let's assume it's a true effect well
no scholar in their right mind is ever
going to try to study it and figure out
why did we why did this happen which
means we'll never try to solve a problem
because we don't acknowledge that the
problem exists in the first place if
there is a problem
um and so yeah like these concerns about
harms to women in science very they
definitely have potential to actually
cause harm to women in science because
we're ignoring uh potential disparity
that potentially could be fixed by
something and we'll just never look for
the thing that could fix it you know
it's uh two studies that that come to
mind for me that one being about uh
women with female bosses reporting lower
levels of job satisfaction
and then a second one that looked at
uh male academics being more reticent to
collaborate with female academics post
me too yeah
yeah
I mean yeah it's that's that's another
thing is like it's hard to anticipate
what the consequences of any one thing
are going to be of any one scientific
finding or any one social movement you
know so like even if you think you're
avoiding harm
you might also be creating harm and
Truth has taken a hit you know so like
these aren't questions that are being
studied empirically these are just
assumptions people have people just
assume
this is going to be bad
um but they don't bother to actually
figure out if it's going to be bad and
if it is going to be bad is that the
only way it's going to be bad or is it
going to be bad if you suppress the
science uh like my big concern is I'm
like people shouldn't trust science
anymore like there's so much political
[__] going on
um that even if we thought it was for
the right reasons for whatever
Progressive values Scholars care about
if they're successfully pursuing those
well they've undermined the institution
of Science and no one trusts us anymore
because we look like a bunch of
political hacks and it's true like I
don't even think we can deny that that's
what's happening so I mean some people
try to but
uh you know you can look at our our
shitty track record if you look at like
the replication crisis and all of the
contradictions Just being pumped out
into the world day after day it's a it's
a sad State of Affairs
I think there's a really lovely framing
generally for a lot of things that are
going on within media
um that are pushing
uh purposefully obfuscated truths or
like outright lying about certain things
that Downstream from that there are
second third fourth order effects that
people aren't aware of that can be more
harmful than an uncomfortable tasting
medicine with a spoon of sugar to take
it down type thing I remember the uh
Chelsea cona boy article from The New
York Times uh maternal instinct is a
myth that men created it's like okay
that's sure that's an opinion I suppose
that was backed up by some really shitty
like very is it like they created it so
that they wouldn't have to do parenting
uh it was to keep women under the thumb
I think to keep them sort of as domestic
prostitutes might have been one of the
lines that was used
um but my point being that like okay so
maybe that is uh comforting to women who
are from a particular cohort the you
know career women who are doing these
things but it's very damaging to women
who have a maternal Instinct and now
they think oh right I've been [__]
rubed by the patriarchy and being
marionette did by like [__] Andrew
Titan Dan Bilzerian have got a hold of
like what it is that like the way that I
I show up in the world so the actual
real world harm of being trying to be
overly sympathetic or empathetic towards
disadvantaged groups yeah I think it's a
really really nice framing that harm in
the
immediate avoiding immediate harm can
cause much worse harm down the road and
doing that also destroys truth and also
kind of wrecks the entire scientific
process but what what do you say to the
people who would push back and say men
and women are psychologically different
because of patriarchy and social
expectations and stuff we just need to
nudge those change those in some way
yeah I mean some people try to claim
that it's all environmental or cultural
and some people try to claim that you
know there aren't even men and women in
the first place or this is just humans
or something
um yeah I think some of the most
compelling data there are that when you
look in more egalitarian countries
um you often see that actually these
gender differences get bigger and so
when men and women are given like more
freedom to flourish and pursue what they
want to pursue
um you can see even bigger like women a
lot of and this is related to what you
were just saying like a lot of women
really like being a mom and staying home
and taking care of their kids is the
most meaningful thing to them and then
you get these like scholarly career
women who like look down on them and and
shame them for making that choice but
when women have
you know a partner who can support them
because they're getting paid enough
they've got their like Health Care needs
taken care of
but they're more likely to choose to
stay home and be a mom and it's in some
of these really poor countries or
countries where women are treated really
terribly where the women are like going
into stem it really irates you know so
uh if it if if
it were gonna if it were caused by these
like really destructive social
expectations that aim to hold women down
I think we would see that places like
Sweden and stuff you know women are
becoming uh engineers at the same rate
as men
um but that's just not the case and
there's evidence that it's precisely the
opposite of that that when women get to
choose
um they choose things that women would
be interested in doing because they like
evolved to be good at those things and
it's really important for them does a
interesting lesson I learned from Mary
Harrington where the um especially women
at the top the ones who create the
culture of feminism in particular
don't have the interests of the women at
the bottom in mind so she used the
example of reducing chivalry like I
don't need to be sort of protected by a
man I don't need him to hold the door
open for me I don't need him to pull my
chair out I don't need him to pay for
the first date etc etc like you know
this is the egalitar and it's a again
your um
holding up your morally grandstanding
for a disadvantaged group and you're
almost presuming that hoping that they
can take care of themselves they're
you're reducing dependency but what
those women at the top the Bourgeois
sort of feminist Believers don't realize
is that there are women at the bottom
for whom their partner might not have
had might have grown up in a single
parent household might have been abused
by a father like they could do with
understanding protecting women which is
really what opening the door and pulling
the chair out is about it's like
treating them in a more a less robust
way is Upstream from don't hit your wife
yeah
right just a little bit Yeah but the the
point of women is something that require
protecting and providing for is
something that can be dispensed with if
you are part of some like high for
leading class but necessarily doesn't
work down at the bottom and it feels a
little bit right the same as what you're
talking about here there was this really
really great study that uh Alexander
date Sykes just put out I'm going to
bring him on to talk about in a couple
of weeks uh 55 of single men haven't
approached a woman in the last year
77 of women say that they were
approached more but that is in the 18 to
30 age bracket at 41 plus the trend
flips and 55 percent of women said that
they didn't want to be approached
question being who is writing all of the
op-eds saying men stop approaching women
it's the women that are in that age
bracket
so it's in there you're are you saying
so it's the older women who are saying
stop approaching women and it's the
women who aren't getting approached and
so they're like taking out competition
stop hitting on the 20 year old
homosexual women and intersectional
competition is is killing ladies perhaps
yeah and they're there I'm wondering
that a lot with them so one finding we
see is uh that there was I asked a
question of psychology professors like
should professors be fired for having
sex with their students and you see that
men are more likely to say no this
should be and women are like yeah they
should be fired and it's like okay on
the one hand like maybe women are
looking out for their uh own interests
they don't you know or maybe they're
looking out for young women they're like
don't want women being harassed by these
older professors but also maybe these
older professors are like we don't want
our mating pool hooking up with the 24
year old grad students
um so it's hard to tease these things
apart but yeah a lot of the time there's
this and I'm I'm sort of torn like I I
think there's probably some validity to
both perspectives like on the one hand
women do have especially women who are
older and who have kids they have these
like maternal instincts and these desire
to protect young people at the same time
young women are also often their
competitors for mates so um you know if
you can prevent the the 45 year old
professor in their Department you're a
40 year old female professor and you're
single you don't want him dating the the
28 year old grad student you know yeah
there was two there's two examples that
I think about one is a bill burbitt uh
where he says
um
the reason that girls on average that
women are more uh body positive is
because they want their fat friends to
not get skinny so that it's intersexual
competition all over again I know you're
beautiful as you are loser toe you fat
[__] like that's his that's this bit
that he does about this like diabetic
diabetic woman yeah and then I saw a
study that suggested
um women are more
they're more disparaging of like relaxed
sexual standards if they have sons and
the most sons that they have the more
that that increases
hmm
uh they're more disparaging of relaxed
sections and for men or for women if
they have for women for women
um
I'm not sure I thought I just thought
that was really interesting I'm gonna
say you might want the girls to be
because then your son can have a lot of
kids if the women are just handing it
out but I wonder whether if you did do
that the man is going to need to work
harder to try and hold on to his partner
he's basically got a less secure mate
that's true so like the a woman who
wouldn't necessarily be a good mom and
help take care of the the grandkids yeah
that's that's an interesting perspective
that I find the whole like I often
wonder why Society doesn't shame men
more often because it seems like it
would be really important to control
males sexual behavior because they can
do so much damage like as we were saying
a woman can only have a handful of
babies in her lifetime a men can father
hundreds of children uh and not take
care of any of them at least like now
you know depending where you live you
have to pay some pretty steep child
support but that wasn't always the case
and so I find it quite perplexing
um if there's anyone who studies this
topic you should bring them on because
I'm really curious too you'll put your
bro signs hat on and and explain why you
think there's this disparity in [__]
shaming
um
it could be because [__] shaming is
mainly happening for women against other
women and men don't care that much about
other men's sexual behavior because you
know they they're only going to
monopolize a woman for like 10 minutes
or whatever
um so it might be that it's really and
it might be that men only [__] shame
women a little bit because women do but
women such shame them more so it could
just be a female intersexual competition
thing and and but I also think women
could such shame men
but maybe they don't
um because men don't care about being
slut-shamed so there's no more people
about all of the women that I'm sleeping
with oh so okay so pre-selection the
fact that a man who is designed by
multiple women is seen as desirable on
average by more women it's the reason
why guys should have photos on their
Tinder profile with them with other
women because it shows that you're not
like a total basement dweller some women
think I'm cool yeah exactly exactly I'm
not totally repulsive to women
um and because of that if a woman does
start trying to call out a man's sexual
exploits because it is probably positive
expected value on his status it's a
pointless thing like if you think about
what it only makes them look better yeah
exactly but think about think about like
the insults that get thrown around on
the internet the first one from any
woman or man to a woman is [__] and the
first one from any man or woman to a man
is cuck or soy boy or insa right so it's
disparaging a lack of sexual Chastity on
one side and the lack of sexual
experience on the other because those
are the most valuable things that they
have to offer so yeah that's really
interesting but it is it's strange to me
that we haven't somehow as a society
managed to make it an insult to a man to
call him a man [__] but we haven't uh
because I really do think like
I'm like one or two percent Mongolian
which I think must mean that Genghis
Khan was my great great great
grandmother and he raped everybody in
like the whole world uh like why
wouldn't we want to handle
discourage uh someone from monopolizing
that much of the uh
The Mating pool but well you wouldn't
exist if that was the case I guess I
wouldn't I guess I wouldn't so thank God
yeah this is the oddest type of
euthanasia desire that I've ever heard
in my entire life I wanted my genetic
line to have ended 50 Generations ago
please
I guess a lot of us wouldn't be here
what percentage of us are related some
insane percentages wasn't there a point
you might know this I don't know whether
it's your field of expertise wasn't
there a point where there was like 8 000
Homo sapiens left on the planet and we
were all in Indonesia or some [__]
we've gone we've gone through I don't
know all the specifics of it but we have
gone through some points where things
were getting a little precarious and
bounced back apparently so that's good
is maybe good for all the people who are
paranoid about AI killing us all like if
at least you know a few hundred of a
hundred of us can survive maybe we'll
fight the road it's a few hundreds a few
hundred sufficiently sociosexual if you
pick like the the 200 at least
sociosexual people here everyone's just
gonna you know I'm gonna go and Whittle
myself something out of this tree and
die I want it to be like a bunch of
elderly people that would do us no good
yeah it would not be that would not be
good evolutionary psychology one of your
areas of expertise one of my areas of
obsession why do you think it is that
evolutionary psychology is so detested
um yeah so this is the talk I give at H
Fest and it was it was definitely not
something that I was trying to to uh
discover my purpose wasn't to know why
people hate evolutionary psychology or
behavioral genetics which is the other
one that people hate
um but pretty much all of the
controversial conclusions in Psychology
um the ones that will get you in trouble
they all kind of come from evolutionary
psychology and behavioral genetics and
it's because people dislike conclusions
um that regard group differences so
gender differences or race differences
specifically
and they especially don't like those
conclusions if they're supported by an
evolutionary explanation or a behavioral
genetic explanation and those two kind
of go hand in hand because you know
Evolution works on uh our genes so I
keep ripping out my earbuds
um so when it comes to the kinds of
conclusions that are going to really
irritate people people are gonna they're
gonna tend to be in evolutionary
psychology and behavioral genetics and
the kind they're really going to love
are going to be in like social
psychology so it's all these
every group difference is caused by
discrimination
um every group differences is caused by
like cultural expectations of people you
know men and women are no different if
it weren't for the fact that we make
girls wear pink and make them take
ballet class
um whereas evolutionary psychologists
are like no there are very good reasons
to expect that men and women would
evolved throughout different bodies
which they do have and different brains
which they do have that lead to
different you know General personality
differences
um and then and then people specifically
are like especially hate these
differences if as we were talking about
the start of this conversation if the
differences favor men over women or if
they favor like specifically white
people over black people so if there's
anything where white people are
outperforming black people or women or
men are outperforming women and then you
provide an evolutionary or genetic
explanation for that those are the kinds
of things I didn't get you fired uh
they're gonna get your paper retracted
um and people are going to call you all
kinds of names so yeah evolutionary
psychology is kind of screwed I think uh
especially as things move toward this
let's be careful and avoid the
potentially harmful topics as women take
over Academia I you would think that
people are going to become more
accepting of evolutionary psychology
because they kind of have been for a
little while but we might be at a
turning point
I think it's actually quite likely to
yeah wouldn't that be a shame if there's
been all of this time time spent
with behavioral genetics and
evolutionary psychology kind of
dispensing some of the uh slime that
maybe it had accumulated or was thrown
at it and slowly over time you know if
you if you want to avoid the replication
crisis two places in one three or an
evolutionary psychology and behavioral
genetics that's so true yeah the two
places that haven't been slammed in a
place you don't want to be is social
psychology so it's the least reliable of
all of the different psychology
disciplines has been the one which is
currently the most On The Rise the one
that is politically emotionally the most
upheld in order to be able to support
um yeah it's very very backward but it
would be a shame if we've done all of
that work you know you and your field
have done all of this work to get it to
the stage where it's regarded in
relatively neutral light for a uh what
did we call it the academics uh the
academic this academic sex ratio
hypothesis what the [__] did we call it
yeah whatever ratio gender ratio
hypothesis whatever yeah um so you you
tried to work this out you tried to do a
study about taboos and censorship and
for this you tried to recruit every
psychology professor in the U.S
at the top 130 institutions yeah okay I
tried I only got like 10 or 11 of them
but so I was like about 500 people quite
a lot yeah kind of quite a lot
um and we see these
my favorite one so I I so after I
interviewed I interviewed around 40 or
so and I sound like what are the most
controversial conclusions and that's how
I discovered it's these types of
conclusions with these differences
um and if they have evolved people
really don't like those conclusions but
then I asked a follow-up sample of these
like around 500 people
um their views about these conclusions
and one of them is that men and women
evolve different psychological
characteristics and
a finding we see across all of the
conclusions but this one it's the most
entertaining is that men are pretty sure
that that conclusion is true and women
are like very on the fence about it so
the mean for women is closer to like the
midpoint
um whereas men are sort of clustered
toward the top of the scale and so we
see across all controversial conclusions
that men think they're more likely to be
empirically correct whereas women are
more likely to think that they're false
um and then we see that the people who
think that they're true are
self-censoring more which inevitably
means that what we hear publicly about
controversial conclusions is
systematically distorted and the
impression is that these bad
controversial conclusions are false and
they're Fringe and No One Believes
they're true people believe they're true
it's just they won't talk about it out
loud
um
so it it really distorts the perception
of scientific consensus anytime you get
like one of these one of these
conclusions that has potential to get
you in trouble
um and then we looked at like all these
kinds of things for example
I asked
um professors imagine a scholar who
forwards an evolutionary or genetic
explanation for a group difference that
favors men over women or white people
over black people what should happen to
a scholar who would forward such a
conclusion and across the board we see
gender differences here whereas female
psychology professors are more likely to
support ostracizing them calling them
racist or sexist or bigoted shaming them
on social media not publishing their
work even if it has Merit not hiring
them even if they meet typical standards
and so women like their their moral
concerns will
uh makes them which is sort of strange
so I think men might be slightly more
punitive than women in general but in
this particular context women are more
punitive across the board
um toward their peers who forward
controversial conclusions or conclusions
that they don't like because they
perceive them as potentially like
morally bad
um
so yeah I'm quite I'm quite worried for
the future of science uh at least at
least the version of it that that I
thought was what we were doing um but it
just might completely transform into
something quite different
um
maybe that'll be good I don't know have
you got any idea how
um supporting or not supporting
groups are if you were to give a
behavioral genetics or evolutionary
psychology explanation for racial or sex
differences between groups that favored
women or favored minorities
so I didn't ask that one because it was
not so actually it was specifically
engine does not controversial so when I
interviewed uh uh the first round of
psychology professors there were they
were like well it's only controversial
if the conclusion favors men over women
it's only controversial if it favors
white people over black people and so
it's really this like particular kind
it's it's conclusions that have
potential to portray groups that are
perceived as vulnerable or disadvantaged
um if you portray them more negatively
than the group that is perceived as you
know powerful or Advantage so it's
essentially white men
um so you can publish things about white
men being bad at something but you can't
publish uh things about other groups
would they be happy with that being a
behavioral genetics or evolutionary
psychology explanation do you think
yeah that's a good question I reckon
they wouldn't I reckon they wouldn't for
the reason that that opens the door to a
different piece of research like what
the easiest way to do this is to
delegitimize all of behavioral genetics
and all of evolutionary psychology carte
blanche because Downstream like the
presumption is that this has been used
previously in a nefarious way or this
could be used in a politically uh
inconvenient way even if it's real uh so
if we just say that this is off the
table I would guess that on average
you're going to find that basic
behavioral genetic and evolutionary
psychology explanations even if they do
favor underrepresented groups are going
to be pushed away I think those would be
less less controversial but I think
you're right that they still would be
somewhat controversial because people
would fear
um the legitimizing the the approach to
the question
um so for example some people seem to
not like that um you know if you look at
the NBA in the United States
that's overwhelmingly uh
African-Americans playing in the NBA in
the United States they're vastly
disproportionately represented
um and so some people said well you know
because of different evolutionary
pressures a group in different or you
know evolved in different environments
has caused different body structures
um and so you provide an evolutionary
explanation while black men are better
at basketball than white men uh on
average and there is some resistance to
that and I think it's because of the
implication that there are differences
right and that it makes sense that there
would be differences given that
different populations evolved in
different climates
um so yeah I think it would be less
controversial but it still would be
controversial and especially for people
who are like sort of Savvy and know like
well if I commit to this what else am I
potentially committing to
yeah okay so you found there was four of
these most taboo conclusions that you
found men and women have different
psychological characteristics because of
evolution biological sex is a binary for
the majority of people
the tendency to engage in sexually
coercive Behavior likely evolved because
it conferred some evolutionary
advantages on men who engaged in such
Behavior
gender biases are not the most important
drivers of the underrepresentation of
women in stem Fields so like those
that's like that's all headlines that
I've read for the last two years have
fallen to one of those buckets those are
four of the ten there were other ones
related to uh race as well and then
there are other ones related to politics
so just even the idea that psychology
discriminates against conservatives some
people mentioned
um or the idea that Academia you know if
it doesn't discriminate against black
people what does that say so sorry
that's that's an interesting one I
didn't know about the conservative side
but what's interesting there is that
conservatives aren't an underrepresented
group
are
oh they are in Psychology not in not in
the world yeah but that's the point
right so um in the world it's not like
it's not like conservatives are some
maligned group that have needed to be
upheld morally so that one to me screams
much more about motivated reasoning that
if you pull academics on average
especially now modern Academia they're
leaning pretty hard left so that that's
just like out group tribal bias hmm
yeah people have been debating that when
some people say that it's that it's just
conservatives aren't good at science or
they just don't like science
um but there have been other studies
like in in bar and lambers and they like
academics will straight up say that they
would discriminate against conservatives
and hiring and talk invites and things
like that so
there's good reason to believe people
are just discriminating against
conservatives uh Scott Galloway taught
me maybe it's a third or fifty percent
of democrat parents fear that their
child will marry a Republican
really huge and people just admit it
they don't even feel ashamed right if
you track if you track
um political bias against uh racism yeah
like people are way more politically
racist than they are racially racist by
a huge it's like by
lots of lots of multiples yeah it's true
it's true and and yet we don't care as
much about that one for some reason
what's because the interesting thing
there is that like your politics tell me
a lot more about you than your race
right they tell me more about your world
view at least how you show up in the
world probably than your race it's the
same reason in the UK that again people
are more prejudiced against those with
different accents than those with
different skin colors this is a study
that was done that was really
interesting and quite rightly like
somebody walks into a room that is of A
different race to you but speaks in a
similar accent you have an awful lot
more in common with that person than
someone who walks into the room with the
same skin color as you but a different
accent right because especially
especially especially in the UK and I
learned this from someone who was
British
um the UK's got such a rigid class
system and accent denotes an awful lot
of that class right so I can tell is
somebody from an area that's similar to
me or different than me so we played
this game I went to a retreat a couple
of weeks ago in LA and there was one
other British guy there and we were
talking about like a similar sort of
thing this guy had like he had quite a
nice it's Ed from uh like he's a
YouTuber and uh he's got a nice British
accent I think he grew up in the
Cotswolds which is like quite a fancy
sort of Countryside place and the guys
are like what class do you think he is
like tell me what you know about him
just based on the way he speaks I hadn't
met this guy before and I was able to
pin him down to pretty much the region
he was in the uh class that he grew up
in I knew that he went to private school
I knew that he was University educated I
knew this this or this and this and this
just from the way that he spoke so again
with this like you're there are many
things that are more
um informative about who somebody is
than this in color and yet that was
originally 50 years ago one of the goals
of the sort of racial Justice movement
to try and get us to the stage where
skin color kind of was dispensed and
moved to the side and now it's been put
front and center again and despite the
fact that it is not a particularly
reliable signal of lots and lots of
things about the way that people show
show up in the world
yeah it is it is interesting we appear
to have gone like a little bit like
there are even some people advocating
for like racial segregation on both
sides like well on both sides like some
uh I think it was NYU was considering
having all black dorms which is one
thing but then there was another one
where this group of white people were
like no black people can attend this
meeting about racism because they've had
to put up with our [__] too much as it
is and like we can't subject them to us
surely not and you're like what you do
realize how this sounds awkward
yeah uh yeah it is strange I I I lived
in England for two years and um I was
very surprised by how front and center
class is there in a way that it's not so
much like when people describe people
they often will like and oh they're very
Posh or whatever and like in the US it
would be really off-putting to be like
oh they're like super rich and they have
a great house you know like you wouldn't
say that yeah
yeah the um that that's but I think it
might be because you guys don't have as
much racial diversity so this is like
more of a defining thing for you guys
not many black people lots of Indian
people lots of Pakistani people like
some Chinese people but not uh we just
don't have that same that same sort of
uh split I remember this was a little
while ago now that they were trying to
do graduation ceremonies and they
timetabled the graduation ceremonies
it's like this is the Hispanic ceremony
and this is the black ceremony and this
is the one ceremony yeah yeah yeah oh
gosh I had no high school or something
Have you seen Ryan long he's a Canadian
comedian and he did a famous video about
three years ago that was racists and
anti-racists early on everything and him
and his friend Danny wore the same
t-shirt and it was like we believe that
the most important thing is your skin
color yes high five they go we believe
that black children and white children
should not be educated together yes and
they keep on agreeing on [__] so good
yeah I did see that that was really
funny and it is
strange that it's slightly accurate at
least in some groups of people yeah
unfortunately okay so going back to your
study this one where you tried to get
every
[__] psychology professor in all of
the US what did the professors say about
how to handle potentially harmful
conclusions
so that one so I I
have princess but I should say like if I
look across all of my data mostly people
do support academic freedom and mostly
people are against taking these moral
concerns into consideration when
deciding whether to publish something so
I had a question
um
how certain yeah how certain should it
be that a finding is going to cause harm
before it was suppressed and I think the
most common response was we should never
suppress scientific findings and then
there was like a little bit for like
high tiers like there should be evidence
that the only way to prevent the harm is
to suppress the finding and you get
almost nobody down at the bottom which
is like um
something like there should be it should
seem like it could cause harm or
something like that and the reason to me
that is semi-puzzling is because those
nature Springer guidelines I was talking
about earlier that very much seems to be
their threshold their threshold seems to
be like if it seems like it could cause
harm then we will reject or retract
papers but but almost no psychology
professors think that that is the
appropriate place to draw the line like
a few people in my whole entire sample
and so that makes me wonder like
how is it that the perception of where
the field is going and what people want
is actually what the extremists want
um and is it that the extremists are
like trying to get these positions of
power to influence policy which seems
quite possible to me like if you're
really motivated maybe you're like I'll
do that job even though I don't think
being an editor would be all that much
fun but you got a lot of power
um is that happening or disproportionate
representation in terms of just how loud
they are online
yes so that's another thing is I think
that because we have this relationship
with self-censorship it's the people who
support academic freedom and pursuit of
Truth and who think controversial
conclusions might be true and we should
publish them those are the ones who are
self-censoring and it's the ones who are
really concerned about the harms and
think that you know we should be firing
people and retracting papers
um they're very willing to say what they
think out loud and on social media so I
think there's just this Distortion of
what people want
um because so many of us are too scared
to say anything
um and and it allows people who are in
this vocal minority and that's a small
minority a small minority uh they can
make these bold policy changes and not
that many people put up a fight a few
people have complained but a lot of
people who disagree with them aren't
saying anything because they're staying
out of it because they're scared because
they don't want to be the next one with
the Target on their back what's the
implication of this like we've got you
know this milieu of hypersensitivity
um
I've always wanted to drop that into it
watch me in front of you
um yeah like you you so there's this
ambient background we are concerned
about these kinds of Harms
two pretty reliably robust areas of
research that are being you know thrown
to the side and maligned
um what's the yeah what are the
implications of this or what did you
after having conducted the study and
then looked at the data and realized
holy [__] what's going on like what did
it make you reflect on and what did it
make you think well
part of my motivation for running the
study in the first place was just
because I had the strong suspicion that
this was exactly what was happening
because I because I'm sort of like I'll
talk openly about these issues at least
more openly than a lot of people will
most people will
um people will come to me and like
complain to me about stuff but they
don't say anything out loud so I know
all of these people who don't like the
way things are headed they think these
new policy changes that are prioritizing
harms over science are [__] and they
won't say it to each other but they'll
say it to me you're a safe space for
bigotry that's what you're saying
I understand
let's make that the the clip safe space
the biggest dream Corey Clark PhD thank
you
um so I I knew all these people were
afraid but I was like I actually I'm
kind of curious what is the true
majority perspective or rather like how
off am I in relation to other people
and then once I saw the results I was
like wow that's even more than I
expected I didn't realize like this many
people were this against what's
happening like we had a question this
was my favorite question I think on the
um the whole survey which was how much
uh contempt versus admiration and
respect do you have toward professors
Who start petitions or social media
campaigns to attract papers for moral
reasons and on a zero to 100 scale zero
being maximum contempt to 100 maximum
admiration respect the modal response
was Zero so like people really hate
these people and I wouldn't know it from
hanging out on Twitter like a lot of
them are signing the petitions and
they're certainly not like shaming the
people I mean some people are but most
people aren't most people are just
staying quiet or even participating
um
so I was quite surprised at how One
Direction
how cowardly how cowardly everyone's
being but what I think is potentially
interesting about that is it suggests
there's a lot of preference
falsification going on which is I think
turmer career on I'm probably
pronouncing that name wrong his concept
but let's just explain that so
preference falsification is essentially
when people publicly are are saying that
they believe or support something that
they don't actually truly believe or
support
um
and when you have that when you have all
these people essentially lying to
protect themselves to protect their jobs
or their reputations or whatever you
create a situation that's really
precarious
because if people get information and
and specifically it's that they think
their views are the minority and so they
don't say anything
if those people find out that their
views aren't the minority that their
views are actually the majority
all of a sudden they might be more
willing to speak out
um so I do think it creates this
possibility that if I ever get this
paper published we'll see then suddenly
all of these psychology professors are
going to be like oh a lot of people feel
the way I feel maybe it's okay for me to
say this thing at this faculty meeting
maybe it's okay for me to say this thing
on Twitter or you know at the business
meetings at these professional
conferences because a lot more people
are on their side than they previously
thought so so yes people are being
cowardly and that irritates me a little
bit because sometimes I feel like like
people will thank me for saying stuff
and I'm like will you say it like don't
free ride on my uh you know reputational
risk taking
um but at the same time
those people potentially under the right
circumstances could get a little bit
more courage and speak up and things
actually could change quite rapidly if
they did um I don't know if that will
happen again I have these conflicting
views where I'm like a mine Optimist or
a pessimist I'm I'm an optimist because
I think so many people are lying
essentially about what they think is
best for Science and if I could give
them courage and speak up and they all
spoke up at once then that could have a
huge impact
um on the other hand because we see all
these gender differences and women are
taking over Academia it the the numbers
are only going to be shifting that way
for the foreseeable future there's no
hope I think at this point or no reason
to believe anyway that things are going
to be shifting
um
uh you know back toward male males males
aren't even going to undergrad that much
anymore so the pool of potential men
that could become professors is getting
smaller and smaller by the day that's uh
what's that quote about demography is
Destiny it's like uh University intake
is Destiny you know you're not going to
create male professors out of a non-male
undergraduate pool and especially
because
in the fields that are dominated by
women people aren't particularly
concerned about getting more men in
whereas in the fields that are dominated
by men like some of the hard stem fields
and then like philosophy they're
desperately trying to get more women so
there's all the social pressures are
still pulling that way
um so you know the the male academic is
going to be a rare breed in maybe like
20 years I think so the sex ratio
hypothesis I'm telling you gonna get
intense you're gonna be swimming in it
so the two the two main takeaways from
the presentation that I watched you give
it at Palm Springs a couple of months
ago should Scholars be completely free
to pursue research questions without
fear of institutional punishment for
their conclusions 60 of women said it's
complicated 60 of men said yes and if
Pursuit Of Truth and social Equity goals
appear to come into conflict which
should scientists prioritize 50 of women
said it's complicated and 70 of men said
yes those were the two uh ones that
stood out for me
um yeah that's again it's the same thing
it's used majorities right like
whichever group is in the majority is
going to get their thing I mean it so
one thing is women won't say well for
the most part women don't say social
Equity should take priority over truth
or uh you know Scholars should be pun
punished but they say it's complicated
um which just indicates that they have
this like trade-off that they think
they're making between well yeah we want
truth a lot of the time but not in these
cases not in the when when results
potentially could
um cause harm to a group or it could
spread I mean one concern that a lot of
people have is just spread negative
stereotypes it's like
how bad it is that is the spreading of a
negative stereotype like if there are no
actual consequences like do we know for
sure that spreading negative stereotypes
causes people to do horrible things to
other people like
is it okay if people have slightly
negative stereotypes like the the
magnitude of the harm we're talking
about it's not you know it's not like
gain of function research we're like
well if we if we do this we might kill
all of the humans or you know research
on nuclear warheads or something like if
we do this we might blow up the world
it's like we might like make some people
have slightly more negative attitudes
towards certain people it's just the the
magnitude of the harm that's being
considered to me feels
uh
minuscule like potentially not even
harmful in the first place like
like give me something concrete you know
and give me some proof show me like that
publishing this paper that you know men
Mentor male students better than women
Mentor female students like show me the
harm there there wasn't any and also
incorporate the downstream consequences
of not accurately identifying it didn't
you say that you got reported for doing
this study I did
uh so I did this study I got IRB
approval you always have to get IRB
approval so that's just and there was a
consent form
um people knew what I was asking I said
I'm asking about the most controversial
conclusions in Psychology that were
nominated by your peers in this other
survey
um and uh one of the so my IRB emailed
me and they're like we received a
complaint from one of your participants
um you don't have to do anything you
didn't do anything wrong you did have
IRB approval but we are obligated to
share the complaint this anonymous
complaint with you
and she said and I'm assuming it's a she
I don't know for sure
and this is based on accurate base rates
um but she said that the questions were
like jarring to her and then she thought
they would be even more jarring to like
underrepresented groups in Psychology
and that this was not my first offense
cereal business I've got I've got some
enemies out there
um but fortunately I followed the
procedure so she didn't get to shut me
down but she tried to well what's really
fascinating there and I think this I was
I've been trying to weave together a
single thread between all the stuff that
we've gone through today which I think
is a it's a single narrative right
everything that we've spoken about this
um gamma bias or or as you called it the
lack of uh prescience of of um
patriarchal misogyny then this change in
Academia skewing toward women and the
downstream implications and then finally
what this means that the academics how
it's influencing academic research
itself too
the single thread between it all and it
really gets shown up in that potential
ladies uh concern is a supposed
sort of parochialness and and concern
for underrepresented groups it's
almost like everybody is Shadow Boxing
against an imaginary hegemon that like
do you know what I mean it's like it's
not for me I am okay with this probably
what I'm doing is I'm going to step out
and I'm going to be the benevolent uh uh
uh uh sort of counter weight against
this thing that I presume so it is it's
a very
overbearing very sort of
but it's not caring right it's it's not
the firm sort of mother it's the
overbearing hypersympathetic
um helicopter snowplow apparent mother
um but yeah it's it's really
seeing people especially disadvantaged
groups in just such a
unrobust fragile way that they they and
it's if you actually think about it
that's really really like [__]
prejudiced to go you know these these
poor black people they can't handle it
yeah they're not gonna be these poor
women these poor minorities these poor
gays they're not going to be able to
handle this like don't you worry allow
me white 48 year old woman who hasn't
left Academia in three decades allow me
to step in you don't know what's right
for you you don't know what should be
done I I will be your savior right I I
tend to see that the people who are the
most forceful on the other side of
things the ones who are trying to you
know take these harm concerns more
seriously Infuse Academia with all these
moral values they do and this is not
based on my research although possibly I
could look at it I should do that but
it it seems to be driven by
uh Progressive white women who grew up
like wealthy they grew up they were very
well off they never suffered in their
life uh and well I shouldn't say that I
don't know what their personal backstory
is but you know it's these upper middle
class white Highly Educated Progressive
women and they yeah they think they're
protecting other people it's not about
them it's about these other vulnerable
groups and it is
it is quite strange so there there are a
couple papers that actually look at very
similar things like for example
um there are these papers that find that
progressives essentially like talk down
to black people they present less
self-confidence when they're talking to
black people whereas conservatives will
treat black and white people more
similarly there's this other paper that
uh was looking at I think it was looking
at like what jokes are funny or
offensive or something and you see that
conservatives are like make fun of
everyone they're all funny like we're
all Targets of these things whereas
progressives are like can't make fun of
uh minority groups you know make fun of
everyone else but don't make fun of them
and it is like
depending on your perspective you can
view this as like pretty uh uh
infantilizing right it's uh essentially
implying that these people are so weak
that they can't handle the same kind of
um
you know I don't want to call it abuse
but like poking fun that other people
can or that they can't handle like
getting criticism or whatever it is uh
it it it it does look a little bit
like precisely what we were trying to
avoid like at one point we thought we
were working toward well let's try to
treat people equally and now it's like
no let's we have to treat certain people
better than other people because they
can't handle what other people are
getting
um
yeah so I personally find it a little
bit off-putting but I assume some people
think that that is the kind thing to do
um we need to come up with a a name for
it it's it's like
a fake sympathy or fake virtue
um because it's not it it seems to me to
be primarily done to make the person
bestowing The Virtue look good not to
have genuine impact because if it was
built to have genuine impact you would
just look at what is the impact of this
thing you would look at the consequences
or the implications of doing this thing
oh well you know the first order harm is
X but the second order and third order
harms are 10 and 100x so we need to
actually do things in this way maybe
it's a prioritization of like immediate
emotions in a world where people's
opinions and beliefs are more important
than like real world arms and facts yeah
exactly
oh is this um a friend of mine Maya
grass so she's telling me about a paper
I was just at a conference in Poland and
she has this really interesting finding
where she finds that
and I forget how she measured it but it
was men are the protector of external
harm or physical harm and women are the
Protectors of internal harm so like men
will step up when they see someone else
suffering physical uh damage whereas
women are particularly compelled to
stand up to protect someone who is
suffering like psychological or
emotional damage
um which is really I think kind of
profound in what we see to be happening
is like in fact it's almost happening at
the expense of potential physical harms
is like women are so protecting of
people's feelings that they don't
necessarily seem to consider all of
these other as you're saying second
order third order what are the real
things that can actually happen in the
world
um because there's this deep concern
with people's like psychological
well-being
um
foreign
my current
um world view when it comes to
self-improvement uh marries exactly with
this I think which is that male
self-improvement sees the person as
mutable and the world is immutable so
you need to be the best person possible
and you need to accept the rules and the
environment that you're in it's in
contrast to female self-improvement
which sees the person is immutable and
the world is mutable so women are taught
to accept yourself and to try and change
these support structures in the society
that you're in which is just
fundamentally patronizing right it's
that you see this in Mulan uh the two
versions of Mulan I like like we get
Disney app Disney reference
um when Mulan was first done the
protagonist is a smaller girl who needs
to be smarter and work harder and do all
of this is the animated version like 20
years ago um she needs to do all of
these things to be able to compensate
for her size and because she works
really really hard and is innovative she
can use her lack of size to her
advantage and she's quicker and trained
and she overcomes challenges and hooray
she's brilliant contrast that with the
most recent version of Milan where this
protagonist doesn't have to do anything
she is patronized by all of the men that
are there she's naturally better than
all of the men she doesn't have to
overcome any challenges she's got this
like magical feminine she estrogen Chi
or whatever that allows her to be more
talented than all of the men and all of
the men are blundering and patronizing
and blah blah and that is the it tracks
the trajectory the same with that did
you watch the first one was probably
directed by a man and the second one was
probably directed by a woman you think I
don't know he's throwing out a
hypothesis Mulan director or would it be
a writer would it be the writer who has
more people oh my God directed by Nikki
Caro if n a n i Nikki Caro is that
it's a woman New Zealand film director
was the first one a man let me let me
see uh yes directed by Barry cook and
Tony Bancroft version
thus it has been proved
wow
wow that's accurate and terrifying
yeah well they've they've got different
priorities and this is gonna this is
going to reveal itself and kind of
whatever they do it's really sort of
interesting uh
I should be making predictions about
other disciplines you really should uh
just FYI Mulan the 2020 film the budget
was 200 million in the box office was
seven 70 million so that's a a heavy
heavy price to 130 million to uphold
women's fragility there that's so funny
but look so here's a perfect example of
that right because of some of the
evolutionary psychology underpinnings
and the research that you've done you
have been able to accurately predict
what's going on in the world
right that is a useful skill to be able
to have right had we have not been able
to learn about some of the
predispositions that men and women have
you wouldn't have been so accurate so
what we're doing is we're Expediting our
progress towards something which is
useful and yeah basically you're like a
you're a clairvoyant Savant uh you
should try and have more of you Corey
Clark ladies and gentlemen Corey I love
your work I think that all the stuff
you're doing is fascinating what should
people expect next what are you working
on now that you can talk about
um a lot of things let's see I have a
paper on politicization coming out which
is another one that slightly surprised
me because we see that everyone hates
when institutions get politicized even
people who share the values of the
institution so like liberals don't want
science which leans left to be
politicized
um so that's fun I'm trying to get
adversarial collaborations popularized
in science trying to get scientists to
work with their enemies
um another one where there's been a
gender difference I've most men I've
approached have said yes and most women
I've approached have said no and I think
it's because women are more averse to
like interpersonal conflict and so
um there but but maybe if they become a
norm then women will and also I'm trying
to be like they're not as scary as scary
there because they're really not they
tend to go really well
um
so those are yeah those are two things I
don't know why should people go they
want to check out more of the things
that you do read your stuff yeah I have
a website coreyjayclark.com I'm on
Twitter and Instagram I'm hardcore
which was a pun that no one gets I got
it did you you got it okay yep okay
maybe if people don't know my name's
Corey so that's probably a really key
component
yeah perhaps look Corey I really
appreciate you thank you very much
thanks for having me on this was a lot
of fun if you enjoyed that episode then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
weeks and don't forget to subscribe